Cheers here's to you but you see it
alright thanks for her milk I quest so
the only the only thing that I'm gonna
make you do is just an intro which is
looking at this camera okay and saying
hello my name is Billy Bob Thornton and
today we're gonna be discussing Benjamin
Franklin cool but that's the only note
hi I'm Billy Bob Thornton and today
we're gonna be talking about Benjamin
Franklin one of my heroes so Congress
couldn't decide it's like they're all
you know complaining with each other
about actually sorry you might we'll
just do one more you just be a little
louder just so people can understand
that you said Billy Bob so I got a
microphone on dude
oh okay I couldn't hear it come over
here just have fun with this one though
hello I'm Billy Bob Thornton and we're
going to be discussing today we're gonna
be discussing okay hi I'm Billy Bob
Thornton and we're here to talk about
hey dude hello it is hello if you watch
the show they all say hello they all say
hello yeah I forced them all to say
hello hello it's just a little more
kinder all right you know when you pick
up the funnies okay GUP I'll do it and
do me a favor once we start let me get
three sentences out before you ask me
another inane goddamn question all right
deal hello I'm Billy Bob Thornton and
we're here to discuss Benjamin Franklin
who was a real character so uh you want
me to just dive into it or you want to
ask me something okay so Benjamin
Franklin who real quick I'm just so
excited for Bad Santa - I didn't come
here to talk about Matt's fan I'm sorry
I I know
uh well look here's the thing about
Franklin he was kind of uh um he was
like a you know Renaissance man a
thinker but why not a more clever title
instead of just bad saying it - it was
like super Bad Santa
- I won she quit okay anyway Franklin
you know most people just think about
him as the guy with the kite and the
string and the key you know bifocals and
these are those who I thought have been
they're not i'm light-sensitive and i'm
wear sunglasses even inside sometimes oh
by now
anyone know I'm not an albino god dammit
I mean seriously what are you doing I
don't understand this I'm just having I
just want this to be comfortable we just
want to interact I'm obviously not an
albino so is your partner really that
short in the movie which movie that's
Ana sorry he's a dwarf of course he's a
short that's kind of question is that
it's an honest question I was curious I
didn't know if it was CGI maybe he's
really tall and you guys shrunk him yeah
that's what we did we took a de guy who
was six five and shrunk him down for the
baby Wow yeah only in Hollywood so a guy
like Franklin who made sense would
Benjamin Franklin go to see bad Santa -
in the mindset that he was so excited
about you know horse dude you know what
how about this how about we go behind
this couch here and I'll unzip my pants
and you can just suck my as that would
it be weird if I sat on your lap outta
here okay okay next time it's your teeth
on the table get the gotta hear sorry
are we doing the reenactment a my own
acid